The Joe Rogan Experience did you read
the email leaks do the emails from
people and yeah all the the different
discussions that they had about their
concerns that they were responsible for
this through gain of function research
they applied for a grant to specifically
do a few to insert a furin cleavage site
which is that particular part of the
virus that that raised so much concern
yeah I mean look the thing is like this
gets back this gets back to the same
thing I think we're dancing around a
little bit which is I don't know
sometimes what to do with this it's
highly suspicious I think of this and
sometimes the way I think about my
teenage kids they're not telling me
everything here now do I automatically
assume they're totally guilty of
everything I think they're guilty of or
is there something else going on here
you know
I I think China has not
part of being prepared In My World War C
book is is that is that um
we have to have a a World Health
Organization that's actually empowered
to be able to do things it's just it's
to beholden I think to China and and
there was a letter that came out from
Peter dashik in February of last year
that he wrote in the Lancet along with a
bunch of other people saying this thing
you know this is ridiculous to suggest
that this had somehow been bioengineered
at a lab meanwhile the internal email
suggested that he had very different
concerns that's that's yeah that's
worrisome and I said that I said Peter
this this is not making sense and what
did he say he said hey there's no
evidence that the virus ever exists in
this lab there's no evidence that at
least that's because they destroyed a
lot of evidence they they it this is
concerning they deleted in how many how
many how much evidence that they delete
in 2019 I mean some stunning amount well
the entire database went down exactly
now I said what I said to him you were
part of the who investigation did you
see the database now it's been over a
year later he said no when I said is
that not of concern to you he said look
he goes it was a public database they
were worried about hacking and and so
that's why they took it down I said if
it was a public database why were they
worried about hacking you know what were
they what were they trying to hide you
know so I don't I don't know Joe what to
make of it it's they the the there's
clearly as you said earlier I think you
said were there smoke there is fire
probably but can I say conclusively no
and and part of me thinks we may never
know we don't have a system in place at
a at a sort of global level to mandate
that these things actually come to light
yeah we don't treat this like we treat
Department of Defense issues we don't
treat you know we should be thinking
about this more from a defense
standpoint rather than a public health
preventive standpoint that's interesting
yeah yeah
um when you see fauci being grilled by
Rand Paul and he denies that they were
doing gain of function research what are
your thoughts on that because by any
definition that was gain of function
research right gain of function research
is taking a virus we should probably
Google the exact definition but what my
impression is that gain of function
means you are imparting new ability to
this virus to infect humans right the
idea is that you're juicing it up and
making it more contagious that's right
and and that type of research has been
done and in fact I think it was done
2015 I think in the in the Netherlands
somewhere but if the NIH was was giving
funding to Eco Health Alliance and Eco
Health Alliance was funding that kind of
research I think that the fauci is not
being honest about that I think I think
the NIH is clearly funding Eco Health
Alliance and Eco Health Alliance is
clearly giving grants to 100 to virology
here's how they answer the question when
I ask them including Francis Collins
who's the head of the NIH
they Define gain of function research as
this you have a known
bad contagious pathogen and you're going
to essentially
do it you know use the backbone of
another known bad
pathogen and you're going to splice them
together essentially
you're taking one thing that you know to
be bad and contagious and splicing it
with something else that you know to be
bad that is you're expecting this to be
worse than what you started with if
you're taking a novel virus and you
don't know how contagious this is and
you're basically saying look I want to I
want to isolate the spike protein on
this new virus I'm going to put it on
the backbone of something I do know and
make it contagious to humans we'll see
how it behaves at that point does this
actually start to behave as something
super contagious or not
the the possibility is that it could but
they're not sure so this is nuanced and
you know a lot of people have taken
issue with it including scientists who
work in the field but the strict
definition is that you got to know for
gain a function research you know that
it's going to lead to gain of function
so maybe the problem is using the term
gain a function yeah if we instead
abandon any sort of uh nomenclature that
might be problematic and say
were they doing experiments to make
viruses more contagious to people
the answer would be yes yeah were they
doing experiments that could lead to
viruses being more contained yes yes I
think that that's right
um that is that is research that is done
to try and figure out a lot of these
pathogens they they examine they're
they're not contagious they put the
spike protein and they put some
component of the virus onto the backbone
of a known thing and it doesn't do much
so they say we have to worry about this
but it could turn into a situation where
you take a component of a new virus you
put it on the backbone of a known virus
and it does lead to something much more
contagious and that's what a lot of
people are concerned about here
I mean you know there was the part of
those emails as you know Joe were were
emails that were sent to fauci January
of last year where Christian Anderson
raised this concern he subsequently
wrote a paper saying hey those changes
that we saw I thought that that was
clear evidence of bioengineering but now
I've seen evidence of those same
abnormalities in existing naturally
occurring viruses so now I don't think
that's that's the problem but it's just
it's it's going back and forth and you
know frankly we may never know for sure
watch the entire episode for free only
on Spotify